everyone thinks you're like Johnny
superstar over here like you must have
been sex drugs and rock and roll in
college right
but right like we know that you're this
Windus person either drink 22 years old
drink but you did have a drink at 22
yeah why all of a sudden well it was to
impress a chick we were in Vegas we went
to town this was back when Tower was
like you know it was that big high so
that is peak a huge Buddha yeah yeah he
was beautiful right champagne bottles
you know coming non-stop and the first
drink I decide is gonna be my first
drink ever is patron straight from the
bottle
no chasers just great tequila but I
can't get over is your Reggie Bush in
there the man and you needed the liquid
courage for whatever reason and I needed
a liquid courage to get me there you get
me to that point and I blacked out right
I wake up the next morning there's my
throat is burning I don't know why my
throat's burning then I look on the side
of the bed there's throw-up all on the
side and I'm like damn like what
happened I got the hangover from
hangover hangover from hell
so I might drink of water and all kinds
of stuff the next day all my boys like
man you won't fire last time I was like
really do one of my other boys is like
you turn into the Incredible Hulk like
you just get really strong for no reason
like you were picking people up you were
moving people out the way oh my god I've
seen those guys - yeah you were Frank
the tank that was practice a so big me
star Heisman Trophy rich Reggie but did
it work at least it did okay it works
but yeah there's a big price to pay a
big price to pay